without further ado
thick boy
thick light
better do it big you don't live twice
you don't get a chance to do it again
let me show you what the thick light
feels like
thick light
thick nation
thick light
thick nation
thick light
big nation you know we do it right never
do it light it's the thick light
[Music]
oh you know getting a little chatted up
veteran on the tab not compared to these
guys doesn't say a veteran attack game
but not real
you know what and i never enjoy them
they every single one hurts whoever
tells you they feel good or full of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hey all tattoos [ __ ] hurt using
numbing cream like chappelle did over
there
first of all it's your arm true better
not use numbing cream
another cream don't help that
today we're at my shop captured tattoo
here in beautiful old town tustin
and i have the absolute honor of
tattooing brandon today
[Music]
[Music]
i'm chilling man dan has a light hand i
do this all day get tatted on my neck
ribs
i'm never going anywhere else man light
touch over here come light touch damn
i'm going to hand this over to chappelle
and he can finish up
first one like real tattoo i got was a
football with a crown on it because i
won freshman of the year my first year
in college yeah so i got football the
crowd on it
everybody showed my dad's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing dude
he's like he's like you know you're
gonna look when you're older like dude
i was in florida my one of my boys is
tim tebow i was playing we were outside
playing football it was me tim
uh
vinnie tessa verdi who won a heisman
play in the nfl and another heisman
winner uh
tim's brother robbie who's his manager
he's my boy he bust balls
we're all out
out in florida playing casual the
football we're all sitting around
drinking water and he comes up goes
football king huh
around all those dudes were like
through this like football royalty i was
so [ __ ] embarrassed
football king huh that's cool
yeah
my first tattoo
it was under here this is like uh
really biscuits but i have my friend's
band right there and
the letters really like blew out so
i ended up getting the same design on my
leg but that was my first token entry
one of my first favorite bands from new
york i think my second one was this
gorilla though
made his murder 1988
it's so old on my first tattoo
uh i was 19 years old i got this
ds-13 which stands for demon system 13.
it's a swedish hardcore van
uh that's like one of my top favorite
bands of all time but that was my first
tattoo and i should have got it a little
bit a bit bigger because my arms you
know saying you see see you see you see
i got tatted by the very talented dan
smith and uh i think it went pretty good
it's always dicey when you're getting
portraits especially when you turn your
kids into a zombie this could have been
a disaster that's why i drove out here
in rush hour traffic during a goddamn
flood to get tatted by dan smith just to
make sure i'm getting tatted by the best
couldn't went any better man
my son you can't say zombie so he says
chombi that's where the idea came from
so check out my chambi
chombi1
chombi 2
birthday
went great went great it was uh some
really cool
digital art of his kids and
there's always kind of a uh
a pretty good challenge with that kind
of stuff like trying to replicate every
detail and
and he got him
pretty small too so just trying to get
all the details right making a tattoo
that'll last and look good forever
that's the name of the game so yeah a
couple challenges but pretty stoked
[Music]
it's like a little speakeasy of comedy
come on in to the green room of the
empire
now if you're tall you're kind of fun
what's up guys we're here at the
hollywood improv brenda schaub and
friends we got sam tripoli hosting we
got david ruthless lucas we got me
chappelle lacy we got brian callan and
then we close it out with big brown
bring the child baby
hey
you got somebody else coming through
y'all know boy chappelle lazy coming
through now if you look at if you look
at me
you see i got on a fresh fit you look at
chappelle he's fresh
it's just a different caliber now this
love is tight now this love is titan
gear new season
new
because it looks really good there's no
thing here sold out crowd shopping
friends wednesday night 8 p.m here in
hollywood hacked
so man you know we had the hollywood
improv for brendan schaub and friends
i just got off stage sam tripley lit it
up before i went on that then i went in
there and put my foot in there yes
you already know two guns
[Applause]
you guys have a good time
tonight for your final time
[Applause]
give it up for the thick boy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
big boy
[Music]
i need everything
what's up just picked up the car it's
unreal man it's like a dream i got
allocated friday i'm in your boys in the
ferrari fam i can't believe it flew my
dad out such a big deal for me my family
flew my pops out from denver we drove
all the way down to san diego it's been
a long time coming we've waited months
and months and here we are driving this
bad boy back down to la from san diego
so uh i just i can't believe it man this
one was bucket list moments i'd love to
share this with you guys and uh
unreal on freaking reel so i will see
you on the side stay thick thanks for
watching love you guys